Tips on closing faster.
I find it takes a few weeks to close
while it takes some like two weeks.
Nate Eath, great question.
My biggest advice for that is
you don't need as many leads as you think, okay?
I have closed deals where I've sent two leads
in a period of 24 hours.
They haven't even run the leads.
They've literally just scheduled the estimates
or yeah, usually scheduled the estimates
but they haven't even gotten the chance to get out.
But I can tell by the way we're talking,
I can tell by the rapport that was built,
I can just tell because I've done it enough,
hey, this person is ready to go.
This person's ready to freaking,
you know what I'm saying?
And I'm sending it.
So my only advice is test it, dude.
Test it at three leads.
If you have three leads sent, two leads sent
and it feels right, even though you're like,
man, that seems like it's only been two days
or I've only sent them two leads
but it just kind of feels like they're ready, send it, dude.
Try it out.
What's the worst that can happen?
You don't need to send as many leads as you think, okay?